[Music]
[Applause]
hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today I'm
going to ask a question from one of my
newsletter readers who wrote insane is
Albert what are the qualities for one to
become a successful businessman slash
entrepreneur so thanks for the question
Albert this is a really interesting one
so we have the greatest and largest
collection of famous entrepreneur
stories of any website online and if you
look at these famous entrepreneurs and
how they got started they have all sorts
of different personalities some of them
are type-a in-your-face really outgoing
and and social and others are introverts
and don't like talking to people and
there's no one common personality that
you have to have which is which I think
is good a lot of entrepreneurs or
startup entrepreneurs think they have to
be super outgoing or fit a certain mold
to be successful and it's not there's a
lot of guys who are shy and introverted
and still go on to build huge successful
companies so wouldn't works much of a
personality type but some of the things
the characteristics that these guys all
do have in common first they got started
you know a lot of people don't get
started they have a great idea and they
see other people
later on capitalize on it you got to you
got to do something about it right you
can't just sit as an employee at a
company come up with great ideas and
then get angry when somebody else goes
out and implements it you got to do it
yourself all these successful
entrepreneurs had an idea and they got
started they actually did something
about it they may not have jumped into
it full time right away but they did
something every day to grow their
business the next thing is you got to
have a really strong passion for what
you're doing starting a business is one
of the hardest things you ever gonna do
in your life it's gonna it's gonna it's
gonna be rough you know it's gonna test
you many times you're gonna think about
quitting many times and if you're just
in it for the money you're gonna give up
as soon as it gets really hard and I'm
talking really really hard you're gonna
quit because you don't really care that
much about it you're just trying to make
extra money and that's the wrong way to
approach it you want to approach it from
the perspective of doing something
you're really passionate about it and
you're helping people with and that is
the approach that that all the
successful entrepreneurs take and they
make money as a result because you're
providing a value-added product or
service but it comes from a place of
intense passion it's something that you
would do even if you weren't getting
paid to do because you love it so much
those are the things that you'll
continue doing with time to get really
really really hard so that's the second
thing I think about the next thing I
think about is just persistence a lot of
these guys the successful entrepreneurs
they're persistent they don't quit they
don't give up when things get really
really tough they still do something
every day even if it's small to grow
their business and move it forward
you can't quit you know it's it's again
gonna take way longer than you think
it's gonna take and be way harder you
think it's gonna be but you got to keep
going and the successful entrepreneurs
keep going until they see the light at
the end of the tunnel a lot of times our
chairs don't give it enough time to be
successful they put a ton of energy and
effort into it at the beginning they
don't allow for the momentum to grow and
then they quit because they don't see
things happening right away and didn't
they didn't allow for that time that
that it just takes to build the business
a lot of times so you gotta hit
something every day to keep it going and
the last thing I would say in terms of
characteristics of a successful
entrepreneur is stepping outside your
comfort zone we're really good at some
things everybody's different so you know
I'm really good at things that you're
probably not so good at and vice versa
and we tend to stick to the things that
we're really comfortable with and we're
really good at and not do the things
that we're not so good at and we're not
so comfortable with and and that's okay
you know as you as you build a business
you want to compliment your yourself and
have a team on board who can who can
help you when compliment the things that
you're you're bad at you know if you're
not a programmer I don't suggest going
out and becoming an all-star programmer
but you're gonna have to do things as
you grow your business to that stretch
yourself you know you have to stretch
you have to push outside your comfort
zone push outside your boundaries and
all the successful entrepreneurs did
that they did things that scared them
did things that they would normally do
because they really had this strong
intense passion to build this business
up and so your your goal
have to step outside your comfort zone
even if it's in small increments because
as it is chances are you don't have
enough to be able to build that business
so you're gonna have to become a better
version of you and and continue to
stretch yourself continue to grow
yourself especially if you want to build
a highly successful company so hopefully
that helped that's what I would suggest
and that comes from researching a whole
bunch of different famous entrepreneurs
and you can read their stories on the
website if you like those are you
watching if you liked the video please
give it a thumbs up below it always
makes me want to do more of these for
you and I love seeing them come in and
if you have a comment about this video
if you want to share your thoughts or if
you have a question about your own
business feel free to leave it in the
comment section below I always read
those always makes my day so thank you
I'd love to hear from you and we'll see
you on the next episode
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]